I don't have slides and you might be
wondering why a neuroscientist is
standing up in front of you today at the
School of Social Work and this is
unusual but maybe not that unusual at
Columbia University my name is Zoe
Donaldson I am a former RWJ health and
society scholar here at Columbia I work
as a postdoc in the department's of
neuroscience and psychiatry and I think
what dr. banana highlighted today is
that grief is actually a pretty
universal phenomenon at some point most
of us will lose someone we love during
our life course and for most of us we
will eventually recover from that loss
however despite the universality of this
phenomenon we know almost nothing about
it at a neuroscientific level what
balances are disrupted in the brain in
the body that lead to an increased risk
for heart attack stroke mental illness
and a variety of other disorders
immediately following the loss of a
loved one in addition as he highlighted
certain individuals have hard time
recovering from this initial loss of a
loved one these people are set to suffer
from complicated or persistent grief and
we know essentially nothing about the
underlying neurobiology of this what
makes certain individuals more likely to
develop complicated grief and what are
the best most targeted therapeutic
strategies for these individuals and so
it's questions like this that I think
teams of psychiatrists neuro scientists
social workers and many others can bring
to the table and begin to answer through
the center so on a personal level I'm
honored to be a part of this Center I
did my PhD work studying social bonding
in an animal model and I can say that at
this point we have a reasonable
understanding of the brain mechanisms
that allow us to form bonds with one
another whether they be between mates
between friends between family members
but we have essentially no idea what
happens when we sever those bonds what
happens within the brain and so it's
through the beginning of the centre and
with my colleagues that I hope to begin
to examine this question using a
monogamous rodent species so my
background as i mentioned in social
bonding was with this same monogamous
rodent species it's in a new
visual laboratory animal the Prairie
vole so these animals will typically
mate for life they'll form strong
selective bonds with their mating
partner and they'll show a preference to
spend time with that partner they'll
raise the offspring together and sort of
live this typical home on the Prairie
lifestyle and this is in direct contrast
with the majority of rodents that we
study in the laboratory so both mice and
rats the ones that you read about read
about in the science section of the New
York Times don't form these bonds
between mates they're promiscuous and
typically just the mothers raise the
offspring and so we know the
neurobiological basis of this bonding
behavior involves and now what we hope
to do is disrupt these bonds as a way to
begin to understand what happens in
their brain mechanistically underlying
the behaviors that you see immediately
following the loss of a loved one as you
can imagine this wasn't pointed out
earlier but it's difficult oftentimes to
convince people to be research subjects
immediately after they've lost a loved
one and some people consider it
unethical to ask them at that time in
their lives to be part of a research
study and for this reason to get it the
most proximal mechanisms of what happens
when you lose a loved one I think that
prairie voles are going to be an
incredible useful model so for this
reason with the help of my colleagues I
really look forward to the studies that
we'll be doing in the next few years to
begin to identify translational
opportunities to understand the
biological mechanisms not only
underlying grief but also complicated
grief I think this is a topic that's of
wide interest to many fields not the
least of which are psychiatry and
neuroscience and I think it's also a
testament to sort of the pioneering
spirit of Columbia that we're bringing
all of these groups together and to
Cathy for putting it together so thank
you